welcome back to street talk
we're extremely excited today to bring
you this panel discussion
with three seasoned experts in
artificial intelligence
now it's been over three decades since
the statistical revolution took the ai
world
by storm and over a decade since deep
learning helped
usher in the latest resurgence of
connectionism
however the disappointing progress in
conversational agents
natural language understanding and
self-driving cars
has made it clear that progress has not
lived up to the promise
of these empirical and data-driven
methods now
darpa has suggested that it's time for a
third
wave in artificial intelligence one that
might be characterized by hybrid models
models that combine knowledge base
approaches with data driven
machine learning techniques now this
panel discussion will um
focus on the following fundamental
concerns
regarding the development of strong ai
so what
is wrong with current empirical
approaches to artificial intelligence
is it time to rethink the dominant
paradigm and what will the future look
like
is it hybrid models an amalgamation of
the previous two waves
and if so what would these hybrid models
look like
or is it a third wave something
entirely new anyway we're going to start
with
bios for the folks on the panel and then
we're going to have roughly three minute
opening statements for everyone
and then we're going to go back and
forth a little bit and at the end of the
panel discussion we'll have closing
statements so
you know we produced a fair bit of
content on symbolic approaches to ai
recently and machine learning street
talk is all about diversity of thought
this channel is non-commercial i have no
vested commercial interest in any
particular paradigm
and that's why we can discuss all of
them i want machine learning street talk
to remain
the most unbiased podcast on artificial
intelligence approaches
and in that vein join us next week for a
fascinating discussion with
neuroscientist jeff hawkins
who's built a grand unifying theory of
how the brain works
and his team in california are currently
building new generation
new generations of machine learning
models which more closely
mimic the brain and this really
fascinates me actually because i
we're going to talk about this on the
show today but i'm a big believer that
knowledge representation is the dark
matter of artificial intelligence if you
solve the knowledge representation
problem
you solve ai and i think that knowledge
representation is quite similar to
representations of computation
and some folks believe that the kind of
knowledge representation we have in the
brain
or neural networks are the way to go and
some folks think that
high level abstract symbols like
functions and types
are the way to represent knowledge who
knows where it's going to go but i think
if we can figure
this out we'll be making good progress
anyway enjoy the show folks
and we'll see you back next week on the
panel today
is j mark bishop mark is a professor
emeritus
of cognitive computing at goldsmiths
university of london
in 2010 mark was elected to the chair
of the artificial intelligence and
simulation of behavior
the world's oldest ai society mark has
been invited
to advise on policy at the un the ec
and the uk government he's published
three academic books
200 articles and won 3
million pounds worth of research funding
mark serves as an associate editor of
nine international journals
and mark's research has spanned the
practice
and theory of artificial intelligence
mark is interested in the philosophy of
mind and in particular
differences between human understanding
and
computational natural language
understanding
in particular mark thinks that
computational theories of mind
cannot fully explain human cognition
he thinks that no computational program
can
ever fully instantiate human
intelligence
you need autonomy embodiment
and a social environment for
intelligence to emerge
mark believes that if a computational
process were
sufficient to realize consciousness
we would find consciousness everywhere
because
the same state transitions executed in a
computer program
that is claimed to be conscious could be
mapped onto the bricks of this building
the clothes you are wearing the very
seat you are sitting on
if machine consciousness is possible
then
everything is conscious even the
smallest grain of sand
would have an infinitude of conscious
experiences gaddy singer is vice
president and director of cognitive
computing research
at intel labs cognitive computing
research drives innovation in machine
intelligence
and cognition combining deep learning
with deep knowledge structures
and symbolic reasoning to materially
improve
efficiency explainability extensibility
and reasoning capabilities of ai systems
guddy joined intel in 1983 and has since
held a variety of senior
technical leadership and management
positions in chip design
software engineering cad development and
research
guide played a key leadership role in
the product line introduction of several
new micro architectures including the
very first pentium
the first xeon processors the first atom
products
and even more he was the vice president
and engineering manager of groups
including
the enterprise processors division the
software enabling group and intel's
corporate electronic design automation
group
since 2014 gadi has participated in
driving cross-company ai capabilities
in hardware software and algorithms
prior to joining intel labs guardia was
vice president and general manager of
intel's artificial intelligence
platforms group
now um gadi received his bachelor's
degree in computer engineering
from technion university in israel where
he also pursued graduate studies with an
emphasis on artificial intelligence
walid saba is a polymath a
neuroscientist
a linguist a psychologist a philosopher
a statistician and a logician
he is an expert in knowledge engineering
ontologies
and conversational ai wallet lived
through
the transition from gophi to empirical
ai
one of the arguments he makes
emphatically online
is that natural language processing is
not the same thing
as natural language understanding he
further argues that language
understanding
requires discovering or uncovering all
the missing
text that is not in the data
he is extremely prolific on linkedin we
discovered him from reading his racy
articles on the pitfalls
of empirical ai methods he thinks that
the biggest problem with empirical ai
is that most of the information isn't
even in the data
it's simply missing from the text he
argues we need to perform
analytical reasoning to acquire new
knowledge
and that no amount of training data will
allow deep learning
to do that while it is the co-founder
and principal scientist at ontologic a
natural language processing startup
he was a principal ai scientist at
astound for three years
he was the co-founder and cto of clango
for six years
he was an associate professor at the
american university of beirut
and was associate professor at the
university of windsor for seven years
he obtained his phd in computer science
from carleton university
and his bachelor's and master's in
computer science from the university of
windsor
now let's move on to opening statements
the order will be
gaddy followed by mark and then walid
oh in one word hybrid
but probably we're expecting a bit more
so deep learning
as a technology is extremely valuable
and it's improving at a very fast rate
it's very effective in what it does
whether it's pattern recognition
classification and
some other problems and there's a broad
set of application that can take benefit
of that and actually it is now starting
major deployment
over many markets whether it's
manufacturing financial services
transportation healthcare and others
because of its value the answer for me
is no winter is expected
there's a lot to be gained however there
are some fundamental limitations
to the underlying statistical
correlation based methods
and because of those deficiencies there
is a need for
a new set of ai systems
with new capabilities that will really
enable us
some things that are new systems which
are able to understand language
and its meaning not just process form
and predict next words
systems that are inherently vital modal
that are
able to interpret and use on the same
semantic plane
visuals and language and knowledge
systems that integrate common sense
knowledge and reasoning over that common
sense knowledge
systems that adapt to new circumstances
new domains
new tasks and are able to explain
themselves as they create new outputs
in those new spaces systems that are
more robust
and more customizable due to the use of
symbolic entities
and abstracted concepts and
when those systems have more
comprehension they
display more intelligence i believe they
will be more antropocentric
and therefore i term them overall
cognitive ai
now in this move from surface level
correlation to higher understanding and
reasoning
the ability to interpret complex
real-world situations
especially associated with people ai
needs to really know the world
its entities their relations their
history
procedural knowledge experiential
knowledge
and in order to do that it needs to have
an internal model it needs to have rich
knowledge structure
can it be done by neural network maybe
some of it
but i don't really believe so language
models
contain a lot of information even
knowledge
and they can memorize a lot but they are
very inefficient and ineffective
in structuring them in ontologies in
taxonomies
in causal models and in other structures
of deep knowledge so i believe that the
next phase
is neurosymbolic cognitive ai
which will include explicit structured
multimodal multifaceted well attributed
knowledge bases
knowledge bases will utilize your
network and machine learning
to extract information to create nodes
to create relations to check the
coherence of the overall system and to
maintain it
so we should stop debating who is right
the connection is the symbol is the
bayesians
instead we need to understand that each
of those technologies have some
significant strength and the question is
how do we combine the strength
based on the task to create the next
generation
of ai and in particular i believe that
neural networks
that are well integrated with a
knowledge extraction and structuring
and with symbolic reasoning are the
foundations
that can usher in a new era in ai
in 2016 jeff hinton famously predicted
that by the year 2021
now in other words there'd be no need to
train
radiologists because the performance of
ai systems would
be far superior repeatedly in that time
span
futurologists such as elon musk have
predicted
level 5 automation is just around the
corner
nlp practitioners have said larger and
larger models such as
3 4 6 10 will be able to
converse and understand language
seamlessly and yet
even a modest and brief interaction with
such systems reveals catastrophic
failures of them it's my belief that
the same problem the same issue
is at the root of all these problems
indeed it's my belief that computation
cannot realize understanding deep
mathematical insight
or consciousness and hence that there
exists a gap
a humanity gap between that which can be
achieved by computational processes
alone and that which can be achieved by
humans potentially using computational
tools
three a priori philosophical arguments
john searle's chinese room lucas penrose
argument
and my own minor contribution to the
debate the dancing with pixies productio
underpin this claim if any one of these
arguments holds
then an unbridgeable ontological gap
between computation and mind is firmly
established
well aside from a diet of too much dodgy
sci-fi
i believe a deep confusion between
epistemic concerns
for example how we as humans might seek
to
establish if a sister or brother had
understood
our words or was feeling pleasure or
pain etc
and onto logical for example how we
might actually instantiate consciousness
pleasure or playing in a machine lie at
the root of this widespread
quasi-religious belief that computation
can actually realize cognition i suggest
that any commitment to what the american
philosopher johnson
famously terms strong ai the view that
suitably programmed computers can
actually understand natural language
or genuinely instantiate other mental
capabilities
of the humans whose behavior they mimic
is quasi-religious because
in asserting that the mind is
independent of the biological material
that embodies it
it masks a deeper commitment to a
particularly pernicious
form of substance dualism wherein the
mind can be uploaded into a suitable
computer program
and in principle live on forever in a
future silicon heaven
a concept expertly toyed with by william
gibson
in neuromancer and much earlier by the
author arthur c
clarke in against the fall of the night
and the city and the stars
the underlying confusion between
epistemic and ontological concerns is
neatly foregrounded in the following we
might model a cow lactating
a plant photosynthesizing or the
physical properties of gold by
computational processes
however such purely computational
processes
will never make us milk produce energy
from sunlight
nor sadly make us rich why then should
we
ever expect computation to physically
instantiate
cognition contra model some particular
cognitive processes of interest for
example neural firing rates
in other words although we can model the
behavior say of the planets by the
correct application of kepler's laws
the planets themselves neither compute
those laws nor follow them
and unfolding their own sublime dances
i truly believe that there's something
seriously wrong in artificial
intelligence
the the biggest problem is that we are
equating ai
with machine learning yes it's true that
symbolic ai
or gophi that dominated ai from the mid
50s until the late 80s early 90s
lacked a learning component which of
course made it
brittle in new situations true also that
symbolic
a i faced the knowledge bottleneck
problem
so learning was a crucial missing
component in fact there's ample evidence
that most of the knowledge that really
matters is not and cannot
even be learned and this can be
theoretically proven
even ironically using learnability
theory itself
for example no algorithm can learn if we
give it millions
of unsorted data collections paired with
sorted data collections no learning
algorithm can
discover that we can sort
in order n log n this has to be
deductively derived
this cannot be learned from tons or
trillions of tons of data
in my opinion this zealous drive to push
learning as the only paradigm that will
get us
to agi is not only misleading but it's
very counterproductive
we keep building larger and larger
language models in a futile attempt at
trying to approximate the
infinite number of thoughts we can make
in language
in self-driving technology we completely
ignored the frame problem in ai
that is a problem that any autonomous
intelligent
agent must face even in domains that are
naturally data centric like image
recognition
the current state-of-the-art cannot
successfully be employed in
critical situations because they are
susceptible to adversarial examples
so to make a long story short
data-driven techniques
are no doubt part of the tool set that's
fine
everything we're doing now is a small
fraction
of what we will have eventually when we
get
close to ai cognition
is a lot more than finding a nice
function that covers all the data
i think this should also be done because
this is affecting
a whole generation in my mind that
we lost because they really hang on
to the claim that they are doing ai
and i think they are doing very little
that
has to do with ai well we've had three
introductions there from our panelists
and i think a lot of it comes down to
this notion of knowledge
and if you look at humans compared to
other animals
they acquire an increasing amount of
knowledge
in their lifetime that really is quite a
distinguishing feature
and neural networks what they can't seem
to do
is acquire new knowledge through
abstract reasoning or deduction
so when any human looks at a banana
we place it into an abstract category
what is that category maybe it's
ineffable and are those categories
universal
so you show two images to two different
workers
somewhere in the world and say what's
the essence between these two images
and if they agree on an abstract
category then maybe machine learning
could learn what the category is
but there's an infinite number of
abstract categories
so gaddy over to you how are we going to
solve this problem of
acquiring this knowledge
data algorithmically itself and the
processing of data through deep learning
has value there are some problems that
it can do and it can do very well if you
ask people in 2012
how will we be able to do natural
language processing not natural language
understanding
by 2018 they would not have guessed
what bert brought for example
transformers but
there's a stage of conceptualization of
creating this concept of a banana which
is more than just
creating the manifold that can identify
banana in every
image that it sees and that
conceptualization
is what start bringing knowledge because
knowledge is
about an ontology and structure that
moves from the physical from the
specific
to concept and it does that in a way
that there are many
instantiation to a concept so concept is
a new level
knowledge structures and more
importantly knowledge
models things that can operate and
create
uh expected outcome can simulate things
i believe
can approximate it i believe that by
understanding that this is not
a just a reflection in one surface but
it's a concept
that applies to multiple representation
we can create a computational model of
that
in a more cognitive ai i agree with
daddy learning from data
is useful in many places it's it might
even prove to be useful in learning
concepts
my issue is that concepts even learning
what a banana looks like
is just the beginning of the cognitive
journey human cognitive capacities go
beyond that
and in ways that it's not in the data in
this sense
my child knew what a banana looked like
when they were two
or three and what an apple looks like
and what a what an orange looks like
but then they did deductive reasoning
they said
these three objects plus grapes plus
plus
they look like they are in the same
basket all the time
they're on the same shelf and the store
there
obviously they are a category right
so we we call them fruits and then we go
up in the hierarchy of reason
so knowing what a banana looks like and
tastes like
and feels like is a monumental challenge
but that's the abc of cognition that's
my only issue is that
we can't reduce our cognitive capacities
to
extracting stuff from data now i don't
want to go to language
because there's nothing now called
language understanding
i have no issue with the idea that you
can learn
something from data obviously you can
and obviously it's useful actually it
makes a whole species
all the animal species survive that's
pretty much all they do
so it is huge but if you try to push
that to
artificial intelligence the human level
ai
i think people are mistaken for many
technical reasons
you talked about identifying taxonomies
so the fact that it's not just
collecting several modalities into being
the same object
but having taxonomies and having
hierarchical understanding of things
for example a banana is fruit that is
part of
edibles and others we can construct
those hierarchies in the brain
banana is also part of what's on the
table which is part of what's in our
home
and there's a hierarchy of that so our
ability to build hierarchies
associate experiences and attributes
gives us a much
richer ability to interpret things than
just
understanding data and labeling it yeah
agree
i'd like to bring up two points the
first point to come back to wallet is
that
it isn't completely clear to me that
that we can
learn categories from data for the
simple reason there's a huge
philosophical literature on whether such
things as natural kinds exist
at all so i think we can raise a
question mark as to whether a machine
without human input can learn
categories whether there are in fact
human independent categories possible
whether this notion is even
coherent and secondly when we come back
to gaddy's initial point about
recognizing images and recognizing
bananas and things it reminded me of a
real life example
one of my my best man is a guy called
professor phil thor he's professor of
computer vision at oxford university in
the uk
one of the most highly cited computer
scientists of his generation
and he spent a lifetime working on
designing machines to
interpret visual stimuli and doing it
exceedingly well
i remember many years ago he was showing
me the output of one of his systems
when presented with an image of a horse
standing by a fence
with some scenery in the background and
i'll either assume he consisted of some
hills with some sheep on there
and phil said to me look i can give this
image to my computer system and it says
that's an image of a horse standing by a
fence now
if you give that image to a sheep farmer
they might say
ah that's nice longhorn shape in that
image that might be the first thing that
leap out to them or if you give it to a
meteorologist they might say
oh there's a classic example of a
columbia numbers cloud
in the sky so in other words my point is
that
there isn't one canonical reading of an
image it's always
context dependent now what phil said to
me then well
he said fair enough i take that point
what all i can do is i can give this
image to 100 humans and say what is that
image of
and if 80 of them say it's a horse
standing by a fence and my machine
vision system says the same then i'm
content with that
and i think that's a that's a good
engineering response to the question
but i just wanted to unpick the notion
that we can't that the
it seems to me that the meaning of
images in general is always contingent
on the use to which we as humans
are going to put them and the idea that
it's somewhat naive to say that we
there's always one canonical meaning of
an image which somehow
the computer can magically extract from
that image
when you look at some of the
self-supervised image representation
learning algorithms flying around at the
moment
they do seem to do exactly that they
learn a universal
monolithic vector representation that
seems to make sense in a lot of
situations and
facebook are making the argument that
because these things are self-supervised
rather than having some pointillistic
human annotated
label it's harder to take a shortcut so
the representations that are learned are
really good
and there's a really strong argument i
think that intelligence
is generalization it is the construction
of those abstract categories but as you
just said mark
those categories are probably not
universal
on the sulf supervised the point that
you bring up
i think a bit of that is burying our
head in the sand and hoping for the best
because
that's the the sheep and the clouds
example if you're only providing it
with pretty much pictures of farmland
and not pictures of just the sky with
cumulonimbus clouds or
night cityscapes with those kind of
clouds is it even going to be able to
find
that category right is it even going to
be able to learn as part of its vector
representation
the bits that did that type of
combinatorial comparison
on a subset of images and found i guess
i was arguing from the stronger that we
would
let's just assume that you can even if
you could do that
there's still a problem because the
meaning of the image is contingent on
the use you're going to put to it
right and so i'm saying even without
that's another complication so you first
have the combinatorial complexity of
categories being subsets of
of the whole and so you have essentially
some subset of the power set
which is just this massively complex
space and then you have the additional
complexity of the
use or the purpose or the task as chalet
might put it that you're applying that
that category to so i think even when
neural networks work well
they're not exactly efficient with their
use of parameter space and
and data and everything i don't see
where the really the hope comes
from the idea that just letting it be
self-supervised
that it's going to discover all these
i'm a bit pessimistic on that
strangely enough i'm going to defend the
deep learning
uh machinery so to mark's example
of a horse near a fence and the
background is sheep and
grass and maybe cows all that the same
thing happens in language people say
language is ambiguous because
what i read and what you said is
different from what
someone else read that's not true
actually in both cases
we both understand the image and we both
understand what was said that's the
understanding
how we interpret things and what our
psychological state is
and and what we see and what we care
about so
deep learning will get to a point that
it will identify the horse
and the fans and the sheep i have no
doubt
or something like an advanced deep
learning technology
that's not my issue so the issue is not
in image recognition
the issue is somewhere else the issue is
i identified like that he said every
object complete
now what can i do reasoning about what i
saw
so i don't see the problem don't you
think there's feedback between the
reasoning system and the recognition
system because you could theoretically
recognize all the elements of the power
set of every pixel in the image
is something unique but we have a way of
pruning it down
to subsets that we care about and i
think reasoning yeah plays a role in
that doesn't it
right there's i i have no doubt that
there's a
feedback mechanism between different
modules the pattern recognition module
actually in scene analysis uh if i
enter an office and i see something
brown and long
and it's more likely a cigar than
something obviously there's reasoning
that comes in even to image recognition
it's a it's a feat i agree can i bring
in the topic of context
we need to think about two levels of
context
a task or domain context and the
instantaneous context
the task of the main context is that
when there is a task that humans do and
machines do
around weather or around farming they
look at things in the context of that
task and if it's done by
somebody from one domain it will be a
different task than another
and this will take care of some of the
points that you're making because
it will pay attention to other aspects
of the image rather than take it
as something that is always mapped to
the same set of embeddings
the second thing is the instance context
and this is something that i've seen
just in the last year
where you see ai solutions that are
starting to have a feedback loop
where they're looking at particular
aspects of an image
because of the question or because of
something that they need to perform so
when you bring context in both the
domain level context as
as well as the instance you can
start uh answering in much more refined
manner in case it does provide you
that feedback loop that's required
absolutely uh and
that's the that's really the core point
i was just trying to underscore
um that we need that context the idea
that we can get the meaning of an image
um without a context to me is
meaningless because there is an
infinitude of meanings that we could put
onto an image
and to come back to to wallet i i know
that walid and i
see the world differently when it comes
to looking at language
and ambiguity in language i think kind
of after derider that
we create the meaning um in a text and
i'd like to give an example that i think
beautifully illustrates this
i don't know whether you guys are
familiar with the group nine-inch nails
but uh rezna um the singer created a
song called hurt
many years ago and it was about on the
surface when the nanny snails performed
the song about residents struggle with
heroin addiction
and a very raw and uh and dramatic piece
of music it is
too many years later reslight was
approached by
johnny cash and the team he was working
with
for permission to cat johnny cash to
cover that song
and wrestling was actually quite shocked
because he felt he wasn't that keen on
his music he thought cash might do some
horrible prestige and it'd be dreadful
in the end cash produced
a version of her that is just
astonishingly good
and with the same words this is where i
come back to wallet exactly
the same words an utterly different
meaning is conveyed when cash sings that
song
the meaning is him as an old man looking
back on his life
and it gives a utterly different take on
point so
the syntax of the words is not
sufficient to pin down
the meaning of the piece and i know
while it sees things differently but i
i i don't i think there is always a
context
and that helps as uh arrive at the
deeper meaning of words and i think this
is again
beautifully brought forth in any piece
of poetry actually
of course so context cannot be denied by
someone that
works in language understanding
obviously context is important
the context here is not just the words
themselves
so part of the communication
is the singer the the
text all of that has
one meaning right the meaning itself
is not ambiguous our interpretation
of something is different we confuse the
two so we
we think because me and you might
look at the same content the same form
the same structure right differently
we assume that that thing itself is
ambiguous
that thing itself is innocent it's not
take a painting it's another it's a
painting is also a structure
not a linguistic structure but it's a
structure
you look at it i look at it we see
something different in it
the painting itself is innocent it's not
ambiguous
it's saying this is who i am that's my
content
same in language this is my content how
you read it and interpret it
is up to you so when we say i read it
different
take two books you read them i read them
you read them different i read them
different
but we both understood what was said
so let's not confuse understanding with
our
own interpretation our own psychological
state of mind
our own biases but
the content itself cannot be ambiguous
if content itself
is ambiguous we would never understand
each other
why i interjected and i apologize for
cutting in well but there was a good
reason for that because i think that
you're hosted by your own petard the
particular example of art
is famously one which is culturally
embedded
the the if when you look at a painting
when an
art critic looks at a painting they're
not just looking at the image they're
looking at the practice the social norms
the movements that were going around at
the time
that is why uh when the piswah was
exhibited
duchamp exhibited the the urinal for the
first time
and wrote this is not art on it he was
making a statement
now the the average man or woman in the
street would look at that and be shocked
all the way when the
the pile of the bricks were exhibited in
the taint modern
that's not art they would say because
that anyone can do that but what they're
missing is
what makes something out is it it's
dialogue with the artistic community
it's context in other words a piece of
art does not exist in a vacuum
art exists as a dialogue between the
artist
and a culture which is supporting the
art at any one piece of time so
point first of all so that's why why i
interjected then because you just felt
the example you were giving
was one with that was flawed from the
get-go now coming to the second point
since wittgenstein uh recanted on his
earlier work in the tractatus with the
investigations
the famous aphorism that everybody knows
who studied any
of wickenstein at all from the
investigations is that the meaning of a
word
lies in its use it's not a simple
absolute
definition it's how it's used in a
particular language game
that's what the investigations
establishes and if you disagree with
that then you need to give a decent
critique of wittgenstein but that's a
that's a fairly robust and i thought a
pretty obvious actually
actually wittgenstein the later
wittenstein has been demolished and is
irrelevant since
200 years so
i'm quoting the most brilliant
philosophers of logic and language
but anyway i i didn't say that there's
no context
actually you you rephrase what i said i
i
the interpretation of the image i repeat
what i'm saying
the interpretation of the structure you
look at a building
then everything that this building
conveys
is in it it's up to you to see what you
want to see
it's up to me to see what i want to see
the object itself is not ambiguous
i have a quick question for you one i
think one of the things that we're
really getting to
here is some knowledge needs to be
acquired analytically or
deduced right an example of this as you
said is the average time
complexity of sorting or maybe the
abstract essence of a banana but if i
was going to play devil's advocate with
you now
imagine if a deep learning person was in
this conversation and they might say to
you well
what if that stuff was in the data
you're arguing that it's not in the data
but it kind of
is in the data you know christian sergey
google he's doing this he's actually
building these
tree representations of formulas and
analytical reasoning and mathematics and
he thinks that it's actually possible to
create
new mathematics through this kind of
interpolation so
you know a deep question is do you think
there are statistical regularities to
this kind of analytical
type of data that you're talking about
right there is
in some domains where it i'm allowed
to approximate and i'm allowed to
make a decision with a certain
probability associated with it
but not in factual knowledge so
there are two types of things we learn
we learn things that
okay it seems like i am good at
recognizing objects
i might sometimes in those uh
skills i'm allowed to approximate
and i'm allowed to have to make a
decision with some
certainty but most of our knowledge and
i would argue
if you separate what we know from all
animals now
almost everything else unique to humans
is not learnable this is a i i i know it
sounds like an extreme statement
but i would like people to reflect on
that almost
everything take everything that animals
can do
out image recognition sound recognition
just do a compliment right
what remains and what makes us unique
are things that are not learned from
observation from data from experience
so to to say that this paradigm
will achieve agi you are saying it will
achieve the ultimate
intelligent rat at best everything that
is uniquely human
is done by deduction by reasoning
by analytics it cannot be
learned because here's why all these
facts
are facts by definition they're either
true
and we know them or they are still to be
discovered
okay so we cannot learn them differently
if we learn them the five of us because
we live a different life we have
different experiences different
observations
we might learn them differently that's
not allowed so by contradiction these
things
are not learned there's reasoning and
deduction
take the transitivity property if
this object is larger than this object
and this is larger than this
then this is larger than this this is
probably something that we learned and
acquired
by evolution years ago because a
two-year-old
knows if the ball didn't fit in this
briefcase
it will not fit in a smaller one that's
transitivity
that that is not learned you cannot
learn this
so yes you can learn a lot from data i
go back to my initial point
but the best you will achieve is
animal-like intelligence
or if the problem is finite
you can like games for example because
you can cover all the
possibilities but in infinite domains
like
reasoning planning understanding
language uh there's not no amount of
data that's you know
when you learn through school about
whether it's maths or history or
concepts about
democracy and others uh you have some
innate abilities
to create structures and to tie them but
there's a lot of learning
that is happening through those those
years
and uh machines if they are equipped
with the ability not only to look at
surface data because you keep
equating a thing learning with deep
learning which is looking at surface
data but if machines are
capable of constructing the same
type of structures and connections and
hierarchies and taxonomies
you can introduce them to those and they
can adopt them
and if you are able to convey to a
machine
a hierarchy and relations in an
operating model
then that machine can uh acquire that
and use it
i didn't say we don't learn obviously i
learned
uh that i can i can sort with
n log n we call both types of learning
learning
that's the confusion and language i
agree language i didn't learn what a
buffalo
is by deduction i just saw a buffalo
there are two types of knowledge
acquisition
we have to recognize this the the full
meaning of learning or i know how to
ride a bicycle
or i know a fact confuses the matter
these are two different types of
knowledge
and let me emphasize the difference i
saw a buffalo
and now i know what a buffalo looks like
we use the word i know
so we associate that with knowledge but
i knew
that i can sort an n log n not by seeing
two lists by deduction this
is not from data i knew what a buffalo
looks like by just looking
sensory input i learned a lot of
calculus and i
a lot of logic but i didn't learn it by
observation
by sensing by data no i learned it by
instruction
by deduction by analytic reason so
yeah so yeah analytic reasoning and
deduction
but i want to just make a point on
models i believe that
what we get from the world at some point
is a very narrow signal the way we do a
lot of our thinking and understanding
is based on internal models we have a
model
of a banana we have a model of animals
and when we get a signal our intellect
operate with those models and the signal
from the outside just tells us which
model
we should bring up for that and
by doing that we can have a very rich
interaction
reasoning even if the signal is
relatively narrow because we find the
right models
that we already have to complete all the
missing missing aspects learning is
about
communicating and helping creating
additional models or strengthening
models
and then we can operate even on narrow
signal
based on the models that we already have
for similar things
yeah central to my critiques of ai
is the notion that i don't believe uh
fragments i give in dancing with pixie
tradition that computation can
bring forth consciousness but i think
that's that this statement has profound
implication implications to do with
understanding because it seems to me and
not just me for example stefan harnerd
in his critique of luciano for rudy's
philosophy of information
called lunch uncertain uh stefan
foregrounds the importance of the
phenomenal component of
understanding a proposition so i can
flesh this out with an example from my
own school days i remember i had to
study
calculus for my in my elementary school
for my sins
i remember after a little while getting
quite good at the application
of the formula such that i could
correctly apply
the formula in appropriate circumstances
and get 10 out of 10
for my math homework sometime later
after i mastered that skill
the penny dropped and i understood what
calculus was and that went along with a
bodily
sensation of understanding
and i i contend and honored i think
agrees with this
um that in all understanding that's a
phenomenal component we know and we've
grasped the essence of a proposition and
so it seems to me
that why i think one of the reasons why
if there is a critique that machines
can't
instantiate phenomenal stakes is that's
important for machine understanding
as well as the other component which i
believe phenomenology
is critical when we're trying to get
machines to act
of their own vision to have their own
teleology if you like
without a phenomenal state where one
thing matters to the machine more than
another
you can't really have genuine autonomy
because otherwise
what the machine does is always hard
engineered from the outside
by people like gaddy it's not from the
machine's own
point of view because for the machine
without phenomenology
nothing matters more than anything else
i'd like to
pivot this back really to future
directions and really what we're just
trying to do is improve
the cognitive capabilities of current
systems and i think we probably all
agree that they do need to
be hybrid they need to incorporate some
ability to do
symbolic reasoning now some people favor
a modular system where you have let's
say layers of
differentiable neural networks with with
layers of
symbolic reasoning over that and then
they connect together
others favor one unified thing that's
not only differentiable but can somehow
represent symbolic reasoning
and i'm curious to get all your takes on
which of those approaches
you think might be the most fruitful and
if it's the merged thing
like say a differentiable neural
computer
or a neural turing machine it seems like
any time they get closer to
symbolic capabilities they start to lose
the optimizability they start to lose
differentiability it becomes harder and
harder to actually search that
that program space if you will um so if
i could get comments on that and we'll
turn over to um
to gaddy first it's uh
if you'd like from the software that's
object oriented it's a modular system i
believe
that has modules that have particular
strength that are built on particular
technologies that work very well
together
because as you mentioned each technology
if you look at neural networks
they have significant strength in that
they understand the whole space
and they can they can manipulate the
manifolds without having to
to kind of keep dark areas in that
so having modules that are built on some
techniques
is very effective however we need to be
able to very well integrate those
as part of one cloud systems for example
if you have a neural network that needs
to
extract information a particular way
they
you can have a module that retrieves the
information
process it maybe even does some
reasoning before it
provides an input back within the
embedding space within the language
of the neural network so you can
integrate
modules very tightly to create one
smooth operation
but i do believe that the future is then
creating
a hybrid system that is built on very
well
integrated modules which have strength
in one particular approach or another
i subscribe to that wholeheartedly
hybrid
has to be defined very well because
people work on hybrid
systems for years they tried to
integrate variables and sub-symbolic
systems
but these systems didn't go anywhere i i
think the idea of
modularity is it seems to be even
neuroscientists that
have at least provided evidence that the
mind is modular
uh jerry folder's modularity of mind
marvin missy society
mind comes to mind things like we have a
module for example that's good at
interpreting colors we have a module
that's good at interpreting sounds
or haptic uh feelings like the touch
when i touch something
sometimes even without looking i sort of
roughly know what kind of
object it is i don't even have to forget
the visual
scene even by touch so we have systems
that are good at
very specific thing we have a module
that counts
it looks at a collection of objects and
it says we have six things here
so we have specialized modules none of
them is hybrid
the system as a whole is hybrid because
it uses
everything we've ever discovered and
that makes sense because everything that
we know is true
can be used somewhere right and that's
the biggest challenge in my mind for ai
i know a technology that i've been
excited by recently it's not new anymore
but
it is probably well over a decade old
now and that's monte carlo research and
and the way that we can use that in
exciting ways with neural networks
to do some things that are akin to
planning and game playing and what have
you i find that very exciting so that
that's something i
m my team have been working with for for
a few years now and doing some
kind of fun things uh for example
getting a neural network to
to place games of strategy uh um
for itself um without uh without having
someone
having to specifically engineer advance
um
what things are good and what things
about so that that's kind of exciting
but
the heart of my pronouncement since as
far as they have any heart at all
is just to caution about what what these
things are achieving achieving and what
we can
achieve at the end of the day i don't
see any reason to suppose that
ar systems are still going to get things
wrong and badly wrong potentially
the question for the legislating bodies
and i don't know what everyone's aware
but the eu
are now shortly going to do enact uh
law akin to the gdpr on the application
of ai i was just reading a critique
right for the reading about that today
um and we need to need to be aware that
yeah i will get things wrong
occasionally the big question is would
it get things
uh badly wrong less often than a human
if it does do better than a human in
most of the time then perhaps that's
good enough
what you're saying about the monte carlo
tree search is fascinating uh
mark because i guess we're talking about
what the future is and
neurosymbolic methods and a lot of
people don't realize that gpt3 there's a
discrete search
over the top of it alphago there's a
discrete search over the top of it
these are these so-called sub-symbolic
methods they are
they're still connectionism they're just
ways of encoding discrete information
into a neural network
i think it's fair to say that the
paradigm in connectionism is that we
should have a monolithic
approach to artificial intelligence and
people like gary marcus they say that
we should have a discreet world model
and we should
be doing reasoning and planning and
acting over this discrete world
knowledge
and i think all of us agree you know
symbolism and connectionists we agree
that common sense is like the dark
matter of the universe
it is the bulk of intelligence that's
what we need but there's an impedance
mismatch
between connectionism and symbolic
systems
and i think it needs to be heterogeneous
but is it discrete first or is it
continuous first
and another thing is rich sutton says
that human knowledge is
um it bottlenecks everything so
there's the actual knowledge that we're
talking about in our common sense but
there's also knowledge of the
architecture
itself should we fix the architecture or
should we create a kind of emergent
system
that that comes later
the key word is immersion i i compare it
to what happened in physics you have the
quantum level the data level
and you have the high level the
reasoning level at a different
and how do we connect them how does a
high level reasoning emerge
from data from sensory input
we do pattern recognition we do sensory
data analysis
but that's not enough there's another
level of reasoning that and we have to
connect the two
so i think modular ai specialized
modules
and how this uh this emergence will
happen
and how do these modules talk to each
other that's the challenge in ai
no single paradigm on its own i mean we
do all kinds of reasoning
no single algorithm on its own uh or
or paradigm like it's statistics it's
logic
it's algebra it's set theory it's uh
it's that this is ridiculous we do all
of these things
so how do we combine this massive thing
we call
cognitive uh abilities
into one system so i think i don't know
who said it but i agree completely
we're still an alchemy in ai where
chemistry
was alchemy so that's why i'm
always surprised like very soon we will
have
in four or five years like we don't even
know
how to combine these things so i think
we're still doing alchemy
now that's fine well if one looks at the
uh
neural network structures people come up
with you certainly get that idea but i
guess um
to try and steal man the uh the
connection as folks
for example mark maybe it takes an
ecosystem of individuals and
autonomy and what not to create
intelligence but i think we would
probably all agree that
a human mind even if it was off by
itself on a deserted island
is still an intelligent entity like at
that point
once it's developed up there in its
brain and there are those who say look
up there in the brain we can cut open
the brain and look at it and it is just
a bunch of neurons
and even though artificial neural
networks are abstractions on that they
throw away a lot of the
dynamic detail and the the continuity
they capture some
essence of what a neuron does like
collect inputs
integrate them together and and fire and
and output
and so what we often like to ask is
what's missing
okay if you take artificial neural
networks
what is missing what's stopping me from
creating a huge
artificial neural network that can
operate enough of what the brain does in
order for it to conduct
reasoning in these intelligent
activities what's missing
what do we need to add to the artificial
neuron or the deep neural networks
to give them that that capability okay
um
there's a number of ways i'd like to
approach this
the first uh the first approach
is to say that when you get a physical
system and you build a computational
model of it
you do so at a certain level of
abstraction
so a neuroscientist who's uh
interested in in neural firing
frequencies will build a model that
accurately models
as accurately as they can models how a
neuron will fire over a particular
given particular stimuli to that you
know another one might be looking
at computation uh the cytoskeleton of
the neuron that might involve as people
like hameroff suggest
quantum processes so the first question
is you've got to think what is it you're
going to model
and is that thing a computable thing and
that's an interesting question
uh in its own right because as as david
deutsch highlighted in in in the 80s
and this has been a and laurence also
famously
picked up on this with the with
computational simulations of chaotic
systems
it can be very difficult to model
computationally certain types of dyna
of complex dynamic system and some
ill-behaved complex dynamic systems and
a number of neuroscientists have pointed
to the brain as existing in
some of these particularly ill-behaved
complex dynamical systems
so it may be that we just can't compute
them so that's one thing the second
thing is
even if you have a system that these
aren't ill-behaved
uh chaotic systems you have a problem
this comes from the worker box
uh boghossian in 2019 who looked at when
we want to
model real valued numbers we've got a
problem because
any representation of real value numbers
is non-uniformly distributed along the
real axis
and that can in that can also bring
another degree of
failure when you're modeling complex
real dynamic systems
so i think everyone thinks oh it's easy
we'll get a brain
we'll build a model of it the two
fundamental problems
you've got to set your level of analysis
what's interesting to you without
replicating the brain in total in which
case you've got all the causal powers of
a brain because you're built and
people like craig ventner who are
building artificial neurons out of real
stuff you're building about and without
doing that you're always concerned with
some things that you want to model
and then secondly there are real uh
questions about whether
uh computation can replicate the causal
power of the brain and i've highlighted
a few in that description so
hopefully that gives you some insight on
my thinking on these issues keith
thank you yeah thank you very much gaddy
what's your take on it
what what's missing how do we get there
well
so first uh you're asking a question of
since
neurons are creating the brain and all
its capabilities and deep learning
is a emulation of neurons at some level
why can't they do it all it's like
asking in a computer
everything is made of transistors so
everything is the same isn't it if you
just know how to do logic
or just know how to build memories or
just know how to do any of those
each of those blocks can do everything
and the answer is that you put the
building blocks in very different ways
and deep learning is a very specific way
to put together
a some kind of emulation or analogy of a
neuron
and even in the brain there's a
difference between the way the the v1 v2
structure
of the visual pathways work in which
they get the signals from the eyes and
they operate
in some way they map it and the way the
the
prefrontal cortex work and the way the
areas of the brain that
that keep memory work and keep the
association one is more about processing
one is more about associative
connectivity
and so on so uh i'm
pretty certain that deep learning in the
way that you neural network are very
good that some things are not good or
sometimes not able to do
other things uh correlation is is
not causality and it's not a good way of
memorizing and connection and so on
so even if we use emulation of neurons
it's not just deep learning
but in terms of the missing capabilities
we need to
understand what are the key tasks and
some of the key tasks has to do
with processing and some data
and transferring to a different plane
which deep learning does very well
some of it is keeping knowledge in a
structure
that is associative that is heretical
the see
that is ontology based so we need to
think about all the
constructs and the skills that the brain
needs
in order to have very strong cognitive
abilities
wally what are your thoughts uh first i
love your uh
intro keith i believe imagine a
person uh that cliche
on a desert on a deserted island all
along
i think they will be thinking without
any contextual information
they will try to shelter they will try
to make fire
but the big question and you've asked me
this before and i tried to
stay answering it for a simple reason i
don't know the answer which is
if you look at the brain it's all gone i
mean yeah we know we do reasoning
but in the end it's all firing so why
why is the
deep learning paradigm not consistent
with
so what is missing a lot is missing we
don't know
for example where we know we store
information
we all agree we have memories we have
long term short term
do we know how we store information in
our brain what is missing
is a lot more than we like to admit
right
the human brain probably is
pretty well understood as a physical
biological org
but the mind i don't think we know
i don't want to say anything we know a
few things
the biggest one is how do we store
information i know we exchange
the the brain uh the neurons fire and
different
uh it's probably not the same mechanism
of a deep
neural network i don't know what
activation function we have
and all that but we know we have neurons
firing and
communicating passing information along
but where do we store information
what's the nature of our memory how do
we
how do we keep an image of a banana in
the mind so we have a lot we don't know
what's missing
is more than we like to admit let's be
humble
let's not let's not say agi
is going to be here five years from now
let's be very humble
amazing well um gentlemen this has been
an absolutely fascinating panel
discussion
all of you are going to finish now with
your closing statement
our debate so far feels like it's 60
years old connectionism symbolism
turing machine functionally if we want
to cross over into the world of
cognitive science
but of course cognitive science has
moved on hugely
in those 60 years and one of the things
that's been exciting me
a lot in the intervening period has been
the development of the so-called
embodied and inactive and embedded
traditions of cognitive science so if we
take this
uh as something interesting to come back
to keith's point
it's not the individual neurons that
that
bring forth the mind it's not even a
brain because neurons exist
in a culture a culture which is the
brain the human brain
but it's not even the brain on its own
because the brain exists
and embodied in a physical body it's not
just the human body aren't
existing on its own the human body
exists in an environment
like keith's putative desert island but
it's not just an
environment on its own a human body
exists in a human society
and i think all of these things
contribute to our cognizing about the
world and
in particular language and social
aspects can actually shape i believe
how we phenomenally see the world
there's been some great work carried out
by jules davidoff and his team at
goldsmiths
that explores how the himba language can
affect
their phenomenal colour perception so if
we take these results seriously then
we've got to take the fact that the
neurons exist
in the brain the brain in the body the
body in the world and the body in a
human social context all of which gives
rise to our human cognitive processes
i i get your point the embodiment and i
i believe uh i i fell in love with
george lackoff's uh
uh metaphors that all all of our
meanings and
understanding are related to our
physical experiences the real
physical uh manifestations that we
we but here's the thing if you take
a chimpanzee right and this chimpanzee
lives with humans
all the time like any of my kids
he's always with us as much as my kid
and so
they're experiencing the same
environment same sounds the same images
the same music they're experiencing what
my kids are experiencing
and we know that biologically their
brain and our brain are almost 99
identical this chimpanzee will never
reason
will never do abstraction will never
speak will never communicate
so i agree with you the environment is
important nobody is dismissing that
but it's not the sole unique thing about
our mind the human mind is not just a
function
of rain and sun and pain and touching
stones and all that
chimpanzees can live with us for a
million years and they have
and they will never do what we do the
mind is more than just the environment
but i think if you'd heard what i said i
think for me it's the neurons in our
brain the brain in our body the body in
our environment and
our human bodies in human culture all
these things bring forth the cognitive
processes
for the species that's my position
anyway over to
gaddy your closing statement if we would
have this debate
in june of 2011
we would not have been able to predict
the tremendous progress that was made
by deep learning and there's going to be
so much value to be harvested to be
gained
by people by humanity from already the
capabilities that
uh that have been kind of demonstrated
and are
now being improved and let me try to
look at the next 10 years and i know
you know it's uh it's hazardous to
predict the future
um and especially in ai because you have
those quotes of people that says in five
years in ten years
but i still believe that in the coming
ten years
we will have significantly more
cognitive machines
not consciousness not agi
but machines that have capabilities of
understanding across modalities of
synthesizing of creating
uh creating results that
are truly meaningful and in order to do
that
it's based on having a much better model
of the world
within the machine it's not an input
output
function intelligent beings and
intelligent machines need to have a
model of the world that is very detailed
that have a lot of capabilities
that have knowledge that is structured
in layers and obstructions in hardly
and then to interpret input within that
very rich
context within that very rich modeling
and then
create something and be able to
continually
focus to mark's point earlier on the
things that matter
because they have some goals they have
some tasks and i believe that the
first machines with such additional
capabilities are going to be seen in the
five years
time frame and by 10 years if we meet at
2031 we will see machines with
cognitive abilities that will be able to
understand language
will be able to generate new ideas based
on concepts
and will be able to interact with humans
and be also
interpretable and explaining themselves
and more than that i believe that within
those systems
we will start talking about the um the
hierarchy of priorities and values
so that it can start fitting in within
our value systems as the one that are
responsible for them
fantastic and walid your closing
statement
uh yeah so i like god is
a future prediction i can predict some
future but
20 years from now 30 years from now 50
years from now
the best sorting algorithm will be order
and login
there are things we predict and we
approximate and
but there's true facts in the universe
that we have no option of refuting it's
not all relative and ambiguous and let's
see what the data tells me
if that was the case we would not have
survived
10 years let alone millions of years
there's a system
underneath everything and i think ai
cannot move forward and i'm sorry daddy
but i i don't see this progress in ai i
mean it's like ufos
you hear about them you never see them i
i am aware of the state of the art and
language understanding that's what i do
every day
we don't have a system that understands
what a three-year-old understands
without
even thinking about what they're saying
and the extremism that's happening now
that
uh we're confusing learning with
intelligence
learning is one part of what we do
our cognitive capacities are much more
complex
until we understand the real problem how
big
it is like autonomous driving that
ignored the frame problem
it's all gonna collapse no matter how
many papers we write
no matter how many news articles claim
big things
the reality is we haven't made real
progress
real progress in discovering anything
new in ai
i would like to have to come back to
gaddy that ai to me is like a
month's progress in ai is analogous to
man's progress at climbing trees as a
way to get to the moon
in other words what we're doing on ai
we're making incremental progress but it
doesn't seem to me that it's going to
ever get us
to building true agi in the same way
that climbing a tree will never get a
human onto the moon
okay well thank you all so much uh for
your time in this panel i think we i
think we all really enjoyed it
we've had a we've had a blast tim i'll
turn it over to you to uh wrap up
folks this has been an incredible panel
discussion thank you so much
and for folks listening at home reach
out to us this is the kind of thing that
we can do more regularly so if you
enjoyed this conversation let us know
and that will give us the motivation to
do something similar again